I'm trying to build people up I'm trying
to armor their mind I'm trying to get
them the belief because this world we
live in is tough it will beat you down
the world and the life that we live in
is the ultimate competitor it will try
to take you out it will find your
weakness and it will just Hammer you if
I can help you build belief build
confidence to the point where nothing
can hurt you because you know exactly
who you are I'm no longer embarrassed
I'm no longer ashamed being ashamed is
one of the biggest things that people
nowadays in their minds kill them from
moving forward I'm ashamed of myself
don't ever be ashamed of anything you've
done in your life face it fix it make it
better